Welcome to Burlap Teaches. Enjoy the
video.
>> In this video, I will explain how to
program your Ford Mustang key fob. This
simple do-ityourself method can save you
a trip to the dealership. Before we
begin, please gather all the key fobs
you intend to program, including any
existing ones. This procedure will reset
all current fobs, so they must all be
reprogrammed together. You can program
up to four key fobs in one session.
To start, insert your ignition key into
the ignition cylinder. Now, you'll need
to quickly turn the key from the off
position to the run position eight
times. Make sure to do this within a
10-second window and finish with the key
in the run position. You'll know you've
successfully entered programming mode
when your vehicle's door lock cycle,
meaning they will lock and then unlock.
Once your Mustang is in programming
mode, it's time to program each key fob.
Take your first key fob and press any
button on it within 10 seconds. The door
locks will cycle again, confirming that
this fob has been successfully
programmed. If you have additional key
fobs, repeat this step for each one,
pressing a button on each remote within
10 seconds of the previous one.
Remember, all fobs must be programmed in
this single session. To exit programming
mode, simply turn your ignition key to
the off position. The door locks will
cycle one last time, indicating that the
programming sequence is complete. Now,
remove the key from the ignition. It's
important to test all your newly
programmed key fobs to ensure they are
working correctly. Try locking and
unlocking your doors with each one. If
any fob isn't working, you may need to
repeat the entire process.
Thanks for watching.